about you I want to make you rich you
see the bond trees they tell you
anything is possible no one cares about
reality anymore this thing about
Terrence Malick is that I think that
he's one of the few kind of visionary
directors that are still around that are
making movies actively so we have a
feature called five favourite films on
the site and I was wondering if I could
put you on the spot and ask you five
films that really made an impression on
you visually like his films do Touch of
Evil oh yes yes vertigo
okay love it the third man yeah okay so
you're going old-school these have kind
of a is stylistically they're similar
I'm getting it I do love black and white
I do love the noirish feeling I love the
humor that is sometimes lost son it was
lost on me for a long time right yeah
you are demands a second viewing yes
place in the Sun oh okay and something
new we're probably stay current was yeah
exactly yeah
I mean Fargo Fargo visually Fargo nice
so let's go back through them while we
still have this time and let's talk
specifically about your choices and so
like let's Touch of Evil is one that
really stands out to me so tell me about
that one so Touch of Evil actually more
than visually Touch of Evil the sound
was was striking to me I didn't know why
I only learned later that um that it was
a watershed moment for sound in movies I
didn't know that it's new it was it was
um it was very moving to me
I actually didn't know now I have to go
back and re-watch it through that lens
yeah there was a I don't know no exactly
that technically what were the leaps but
there was something there was there was
something big about that but visually
also like I said I loved in Wash
black-and-whites Moody there was less
humor in that one but there's something
funny about watching
mmm there's something funny about
watching that film I don't know what it
is maybe it's the sort of unintentional
racism oh well yeah it's so different
from how we are today yes it's not
conscious about itself in the same way
that we are now right
no no it's scary it's a it's a movie
that made me feel nervous when I watched
it it still does so I can see a parallel
between several of the roles that you've
played right with those movies too sure
because here you are sitting in front of
me and you are very pleasant gentlemen
oh but damn you must you're great actors
now because I'm always like that wes
Bentley I don't know let's not put him
in a top hat on American Horror Story
anymore because I couldn't sleep so
would you say that those movies informed
your roles yeah I think I was you know
I've always been I like complicated
characters meaning sometimes they come
off as dark because I think people are
complicated and always have a sort of
dark side if not darkish side and and I
like to play them because I don't like
to judge people and I think acting is
the perfect forum for that you don't
because the first rule is to not judge
your character sure yeah so that's a
real challenge when you play people who
are unsavory so that's why that is part
of the appeal of some characters from it
yeah
you